leaders from around the world are in new
york city at the united nations general
assembly a week of meeting and greeting
that was impossible last year due to the
coronavirus pandemic this year this
annual appointment for face-to-face
diplomacy is a mixture of family reunion
and crisis meeting tonight the emphasis
is clearly on crisis u.n secretary
general antonio gutierrez today issued a
wake-up call to the world offering a
blistering indictment of countries
failing their own citizens
and each other
i'm here to sound the alarm
the world must wake up
we are on the edge of an abyss and
moving in the wrong direction
our world has never been more threatened
or more divided
we face the greatest cascade of crisis
in our lifetimes the client alarm bells
are also ringing at fever pitch
the recent report of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change was a code red for humanity now
is the time to restore trust and now is
the time to inspire hope
and i do have hope the problems we have
created are problems we can solve
humanity has shown that we are capable
of great things when we work together
and that is the reason that of our
united nations
yeah the u.n general assembly has an
opportunity to maintain and build
relationships with one very unexpected
exception this year today the foreign
minister of france said that he has no
intention of meeting his u.s counterpart
the u.s secretary of state this week a
cold shoulder from paris to washington
france is fuming over a trilateral
security pact between the u.s the uk and
australia saying it was stabbed in the
back by allies who kept the deal secret
i want you to listen to what u.s
president biden said today in his debut
address at the u.n
the united states will compete and will
compete vigorously
and lead with our values and our
strength
we'll stand up for our allies and our
friends and oppose attempts
by stronger countries to dominate weaker
ones
whether through changes to territory by
force
economic coercion
technical exploitation or disinformation
but we're not seeking
say it again we are not seeking a new
cold war
or a world divided
into rigid blocks
our international editor richard walker
he is at the u.n in new york city good
evening to you richard i want to pick up
on what the u.s president said in just a
moment but another world leader is
making news just in the last couple of
minutes tell us what you know
yeah that's right brent so a lot of
focus on joe biden on the drama of
antonio guterres's comments and of
course uh the strife between the united
states and france but some of the
biggest and most consequential news
actually coming from china's president
xi jinping who in in his pre-recorded
message to the u.n general assembly
announced almost just slipped in there
that china would stop
building coal-fired power stations
around the world now this is seen as
significant because china's belton road
is hugely international infrastructure
initiative has been a major driver of
coal power stations outside china around
the world particularly in developing
countries and we managed to grab the us
climate envoy john kerry who's been
shuttling between meetings here in new
york to comment on that and here's what
he had to say
uh it's an extremely welcome decision
uh we've been talking with china for
quite some period of time about this
and i'm absolutely delighted to hear
that president xi has made this
important decision
it's a great contribution it's a good
beginning for the
efforts we need to achieve for glasgow
richard that we have to say that was an
exclusive you got that comment from john
kerry just in the last hour or so and
this progress that is being announced by
the chinese president and it being
announced here by john kerry it speaks
to the fact that the us it may be
serious when it says that it can have a
conflict with china on some things but
when it comes to climate change they are
working together
that's right now this has been a very
big worry especially in recent months
you know
there's been a concern about the us and
china slipping into a kind of a cold war
confrontation ever since the latter half
of the trump presidency but this has
taken on almost an even greater
intensity under joe biden there's been a
lot of concern but from people like the
un secretary general antonio guterres
that this uh this showdown between the
us and china is going to get in the way
of of working together on some of the
most important issues facing mankind of
course we heard the urgency of the
messages from guterres in the in the
clips just earlier
what we're hearing from john kerry here
and what the signal from xi jinping
seems to be there is that there is some
possibility that that cooperation can
still happen john kerry saying that he's
been talking to china for a long time
about this that this is something that
he's been urging them to do and xi
jinping going on and doing this now of
course xi jinping may have every other
reason to do this of course climate
change doesn't just affect the united
states and just affect any one country
it's in china's own interest to deal
with it too but maybe a little glimmer
of hope that the two countries uh can
cooperate on this issue after all
despite the multitude of other issues
that they face together yeah let me pick
up to richard on what the u.s president
he found himself today with the task of
mollifying french anger over that orcas
security
pack biden also finds himself having to
convince the world that america
is back his america is back mantra is
not a kindler gentler version of trump's
america first did he succeed today
yeah well the jury's still out on that
brent but it's certainly true that the
french are mightily annoyed about what
the the americans and the australians
have done pulling the plug on and is a
long-established deal between france and
australia and kind of going their own
way
and the signal that the french seem to
be interpreting this and others on
continental europe too is that there's a
kind of like like a two two classes of
us allies a signal that somehow the
anglo-sphere or this indo-pacific region
are more important to the united states
uh than these very long-standing allies
in continental europe so the us is going
to have to do some homework i think to
to patch things up with the europeans
now of course you know the alliance the
transatlantic alliance goes back a very
long way it's not something that can be
undone by a single decision but what it
will do is contribute to a debate that's
been kind of bubbling in europe mostly
in think tank circles but i can think we
can expect it to expand about whether
europe needs to be more independent
where whether it needs to come out a
little bit from from under the united
states shadow this will only contribute
to that debate uh in the months and
years ahead
and richard the u.n security or
secretary general today he did not hold
back with his criticism of an
international community that is heavy on
self-centeredness and short on empathy
have we ever seen antonio gutierrez
like this before
yeah it was really powerful language
wasn't it i mean that one word i think
is going to stick out for me from
today's talks
more than any other him calling it an
obscenity the inequality between the
rich countries and the rest of the world
over vaccination the fact that six
billion vaccine doses have been
administered worldwide but only two
percent of those have been administered
in the continent of of africa and i
think you know
guterres i think this is the strongest
language from him so far but i think
you're hearing the exasperation of a man
who's been making warnings like this for
some time and just feels his message is
not getting across and it's not just on
covert it's on climate change it's on
global poverty it's on a whole range of
issues i think you're hearing the
frustration here of a man
trying to
bring the international community
together back here in this building in
new york and feeling it's not coming
together
dw's international editor richard walker
with excellent analysis and reporting
tonight from the u.n in new york richard
thank you